à ces vieux bâtiments ont un siècle à
peu près c'était au lendemain de la
défaite française 2 71
les alsaciens du textile ont quitté les
valets qui était occupé par les
allemands et sont venus s'installer de
ce côté des vosges dans les vallées
rester française et puis la crise du
textile est survenue peu à peu certains
ateliers ont fermé leurs portes des
industriels ont voulu prendre la relève
parmi eux la jeune société européenne de
plastique qui s'est installée à fraisses
plainfaing on en a beaucoup parlé il ya
un an
alors monsieur nilza vous êtes une
équipe de quatre hommes je crois 3 dans
la société et puis un membre qui a un
bureau d'études à nancy c'est bien cela
c'est monsieur et qu'elle oui monsieur
alain bureau d'études voit là et vous
avez mis au point en commun un procédé
assez révolutionnaire de construction la
jeune révolutionnaire donc maison en
matière plastique à maison de l'an 2000
et nous pensons que c'est la maison de
l'an 2000
de par sa conception de par les qualités
qu'elle présente le prototype de notre
pavillon est exposée actuellement à la
foire internationale de la maison pas de
plastique à lüdenscheid où il a eu la
médaille d'or ce pavillon se compose de
dix éléments semblables qui se
juxtaposer entre lesquels nous mettons
des fenêtres en matière plastique
également c'est à dire en place béton le
placent béton al'avantage d'être un
matériau révolutionnaire en ce sens
qu'il est extrêmement léger qu'il est
ininflammable et notre pavillon a
également l'avantagé d'être
transportable sur un camion sable sur
remorque vous transportez est mort un
pavillon d'une cinquantaine de mètres
carrés et qui pèse 6 tonnes ce qui pèse
6 tonnes
vous en êtes à la période où il faudrait
lancer la construction en série bah il
est bien certain qu'à la suite de la de
l'exposition de lüdenscheid nous avons
des demandes de très importantes d'une
part
de l'allemagne puisque la société sabah
qui a organisé cette première foire
internationale à des demandes très très
considérable puisque ces gens là sont
prêts à nous passer une commande de 1700
pavillon rien pour l'allemagne mais ils
sont pas seuls à s'y intéresser les
hollandais les italiens venus naissance
et nous avons des hollandais des
français des australiens même disons que
de toutes les parties du monde nous
avons des demandes maintenant mais
malheureusement nos moyens financiers
actuelles ne nous permettent pas
de considérer l'extension de lusine qui
existent actuellement c'est impossible
nous pensons pouvoir trouver auprès de
français ou d'étrangers les moyens de
créer des unités de production tant en
france qu'à l'étranger pour la
distribution et la fabrication de nos
pavillons au moment où nous nous
trouvions à fraisses précisément un
homme d'affaires italien se trouvait là
pour traiter avec la société européenne
de plastique
ce pavillon de l'an 2000 a donc des
chances de conquérir le marché italien
sans doute parce que pour nous l'avenir
c'est un changement total de l'ancien
façon de faire de bâtir et de faire des
maisons en face ont déboulé faire plus
vite un maillot manches et donc de votre
groupe s'intéresse à cette affaire nous
c'est un an et demi qu'on est sur cette
affaire on est très intéressé et on
espère le pouvoir voter en italie aussi
cette fabrication
quelle est l'opinion de l'architecte
pour cette construction qui n'a qui ne
correspond absolument pas à ce que vous
avez pu apprendre dans la haute école
que vous avez fait traduire s'il tirait
la ligue et l'avenir c'est dans ces
nouvelles matières et surtout sur
industrie d'octets l'hôtellerie et du
tourisme mais et de nouvelles les
fabrications donc cela ne révolte pas
l'architecte qu'on construise avec des
procédés a déjà fait nouveau pas du tout
pas du tout on est tous lancé la
dernière considération évidemment le
l'emploi les emplois qu'il est
souhaitable de créer dans la région de
saint dié particulièrement respect enfin
où elle sévit une crise récente
et là évidemment vous pourriez créer pas
mal d'emplois nous pensons que sur
fraises plein fun nous pourrions créer
ne serait ce que pour ravitailler le
marché allemand 150 à 200 emplois
[Musique]